Hey youtubers it's Charlie and since Korra
is on break this weekend I wanted to do a
bonus video for Book 4.
Because of all the craziness going on with
Book 3 right now I thought it would be helpful
to put it all into context and talk about
some things we can all be really happy about.
And Just for fun I'm going to rank my top
10 last airbender characters.
Congrats to last weeks giveaway winners.
Effective Kill, Khaler Jex and Novelist Vampire
Girl you guys each win an amazon gift card.
I'll be messaging you on your channels for
details.
So check your inboxes today.
Even though there's no new episode I'm continuing
the giveaway this week.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
There's only one winner per episode, that's
why there were three people from last week.
Which brings up a good point, what's going
on with Book 3 right now.
Nick just casually dropped that they'd be
doubling up on Korra episodes indefinitely.
They didn't say "for the rest of the season".
But the next several episodes, through episode
7 at least, they'll be doing two episodes
back to back each week.
So next week when it comes back on Friday
July 11th, they'll air episodes 4 and 5 together,
then the week after that 6 and 7.
By the time we get to 6 and 7 they'll probably
announce if they're going to keep doing two
per week, I really hope they don't.
It's awesome to get an hour of Korra every
week.
But think about it this way, the faster they
burn through Korra episodes, the longer the
wait will be till Book 4.
And there's been no indication that they're
going to tell us when Book 4 is going to premiere.
So Book 4 discussion time.
Here is my thought.
In light of the weirdness that has been going
on with the Book 3 leaks and lack of promotion.
Nick is going to hold off airing Book 4 until
next year.
And use that extra time to promote the series
the way they should have promoted Book 3.
Master Sifu was on twitter talking about going
in for Korra Marketing meetings with the studio
recently, so if they're bringing him in to
help figure out a better way to promote the
series it means they are dedicating resources
to the problem.
Which makes me a lot more excited.
I feel like the fandom will always do a better
job of creating awareness, but Nick is the
one with the resources to actually put ads
in big places so that the general public knows
when and where to find new Korra episodes.
One of the really cool things that networks
have started to do in the last couple of years
is rely on stars with big social accounts
like on Twitter and Facebook to drive engagement
with the fandom and call everyone to action.
The best example of this is Vin Diesel.
He used his own money to make that last Riddick
movie and he said the one big reason enough
people came out to see the movie was because
he was able to reach his huge facebook audience.
His page has like 80 Million followers.
Crazy right, so if you ever wanted to fund
like a new season of Korra or a Korra movie,
just build a giant audience somewhere on social
and crowd fund it.
Here's a good question for all you guys, if
I ever got to the point where I had some crazy
number of subscribers here on my channel like
10 Million.
And I had the chance to crowd fund something.
What would you want to see me bring back?
I'm so far away from being able to do something
like that, but it's a really fun fantasy to
have.
I'd like to think that someday if I work hard
enough I could take something I really love
and bring it back from the dead.
So the big takeaway from all this book 3 weirdness
is that we should be optimistic that magical
things will happen when Book 4 gets closer.
So because it's the weekend and we all need
to have some fun let's rank our favorite Last
Airbender characters.
Because a lot of them have been appearing
on Korra.
I'm going to start at
Number 10 - Zhao
He's currently still stuck in the fog of Lost
Souls as of the end of book 2.
I think he's still stuck in there.
I'm not expecting him to appear again but
I feel like Jason Isaacs brought so much to
this character.
He's so good at playing villains.
And Zhao's voice was so distinct that I feel
like everyone went a little nuts when he showed
up on Korra.
Jason Isaacs even returned during book 1 to
voice new lines for the character in Book
1 episode 13.
I don't know if they just used a dub of his
voice for the scenes in Book 2 in the Fog
of Lost souls, but it's pretty cool that he
came back at all.
My favorite Zhao scene was either his death
during Last Airbender or finding out he was
stuck in the Fog of Lost souls.
Number 9 - Suki of the Kyoshi Warriors
As of right now, she's the only original Team
Avatar person who hasn't been mentioned or
seen on Korra.
She was always a character I thought deserved
more screen time.
She is in the Search comic, but otherwise
we're still waiting to find out what her final
fate was and if she ever ended up with Sokka.
Fun Fact, she's also the only origina team
avatar members to not get a solo field trip
with Zuko.
Each of the other characters got a Zuko side
story when it was just them and Zuko.
But she was never a huge fan of his.
Originally the plan for her character was
that she would only appear in that first Kyoshi
Warrior episode, it was Book 1 episode 4.
But people like her so much Mike and Bryan
made her an official member of team Avatar
in books 2 and 3.
I think my favorite Suki moment was during
the ember island players episode where she
tried to sneak backstage to make the actor
playing her act better.
Number 8 - Sokka
It actually took me a little while to get
used to how over the top he was all the time.
He was always the character that reacted to
things.
Like Aang was in this constant state of child-like
wonder about things, Katara was the voice
of reason and Sokka was always the one who
would have the WTF style reactions.
I really loved him more when they made it
to the Northern Water Tribe and after the
Suki character was introduced.
If feel like that's when he matured a little
and started to get more hero moments.
My favorite Sokka moment was in Book 3 where
he and Katara had to attend Aang's Fire Nation
parent teacher conference as Mr Wang Fire.
But here's an interesting thought.
If Sokka were still alive today, do you think
he would have been one of the people to gain
airbending?
He was from the water tribe, so there's no
guarantee he would have.
But if they let Bumi become an airbender I
supposed it's possible.
Number 7 - Firelord Ozai
Shoutout to Mark Hamill.
His Ozai was dramatically different from the
other voices he's done, but just think about
the idea of Firelord Joker.
Ozai did go a little bananas at the end.
I loved his arc up to the appearance of Sozin's
Comet when he declared himself the Phoenix
King.
In case you haven't read a lot of the backstory,
Ozai and his father Firelord Azulon wanted
to bond the Avatar's lineage to theirs so
Ozai married Ursa, Avatar Roku's granddaughter.
Zuko's mother.
So technically you could say that Zoku is
linked to Korra on a spiritual level, even
if she's been separated from her past lives.
I also know a lot of you haven't read The
Search comic, that's the one that tells what
happened to Zuko's mother.
So read it if you want to know.
He does find her at the end.
Number 6 - Azula
She genuinely had some non-evil person moments.
Like when they went to Ember Island and she
tried to pick up that boy.
Best Azula pickup line.
"That's a sharp outfit there.
Careful, you could puncture the hull of an
empire class fire nation ship.
Leaving thousands to drown at sea."
So hard to figure out why she's still single?
I know everyone is curious if sparky sparky
boom girl on Korra is related to her just
because of the visual similarity.
I don't think that's the case, but I do think
we'll find out what happened to Azula by book
4.
Number 5 - Katara
She was everyone's mom even before she became
an actual mom.
I always liked when Mike and Bryan let her
have fun and she didn't have to be the responsible
one.
That was kind of her role on Team Avatar.
Make sure ADHD Aang focused on the task at
hand and make sure Sokka didn't get himself
killed.
And she doubled as the healer.
We saw her use her healing ability during
Korra last season, and even though we haven't
seen her yet in Book 3, I think she'll be
back soon.
My favorite Katara moment was from The Fortuneteller
episode where she sees Aang super bend the
volcano lava flow and realizes he might be
the powerful bender she's destined to marry.
Number 4 - Iroh
I was so happy when he showed up in the spirit
world.
If there was any character who deserved to
get that kind of an ending it was him.
He kind of reminds me of what Darth Vader
would have been had he not died.
Like maybe if Luke had died like Iroh's son,
maybe he would have killed the Emperor and
started helping the rebellion.
I love Mark Hamill but I think I would have
rather seen that version of Star Wars.
I'm not expecting to see Iroh again on Legend
of Korra, I think Zuko is filling the role
he would normally occupy now.
Especially since he's connected to the White
Lotus.
My favorite Iroh moment was when he was stuck
in prison and started to train secretly when
the guards weren't watching him.
It's like you were just waiting for him to
tear shit up.
Number 3 - Aang
Yes he was the protagonist of the series,
but I feel like saying the main character
was the most interesting is a cop out.
He was one of my favorites and one of the
most interesting ones.
He's been a huge part of Legend of Korra,
even when he's not on screen in spirit form.
Only characters that had a deep connection
to the spirit world end up there, so I'm hoping
we get to see him again that way.
But it's implied that Korra will never reconnect
with her past lives, so I think if we see
him any time soon on Korra it will be in a
flashback.
And most of the flashbacks this season are
Beifong flashbacks.
My favorite Aang moment was when the Lion
Turtle taught him to Energy Bend.
He would have learned it from Guru Pathik
but left early to help his friends.
I guess that's another Star Wars reference,
like when Luke left Yoda early to save his
friends from Vader.
I think we can all guess Mike and Bryan are
huge Star Wars fans, especially since the
ended up casting Mark Hamill as the Emperor
Palpatine of their series
Number 2 - Toph Beifong
So many Toph questions still, her whereabouts
right now are still one of the biggest.
But I'm so pumped to see her and Lin in the
flashbacks this year.
I think my favorite Toph moment was when she
schooled Aang in sandbending a perfect replica
of Ba Sing Se with one stomp of her foot.
Has anyone ever wondered how often she had
to clean her feet when she started living
in Republic City?
I bet she had pretty gross feet walking around
without shoes all the time.
It was pretty awesome when we got to see Lin
take her shoe off in book 1 and use the stomp
echolocation Toph style.
and my Number 1 favorite Last Airbender character
- Lord Zuko
I say Lord just because he's not Firelord
anymore.
He passed it on to his daughter, who we still
haven't met, even though we've met his grandson.
Just like Toph, there are so many unanswered
Zuko questions right now.
I think my favorite Zuko moment was actually
when he first decided to help Aang and was
all like, "Hello, Zuko here!"
and there were all these scary music cues.
Dun Dun Dun.
But let me know who you're favorite Last Airbender
character is and which one you want to see
on Korra next.
I know Toph is pretty high on everybody's
list.
As a bonus, I'd say Cabbage Man is one of
my favorites.
He's one of the best running gags on both
series.
Back in book 1 I saw a bunch of theories that
Cabbage Corp was secretly going to be the
ultimate villains of the new series.
Which is funny to think about.
We just saw him in Book 3 episode 1, he was
the one Korra almost hit with Asami's Car.
So remember, two new episodes of Korra next
friday.
Episodes 4 and 5.
Because of the weird way they're doing episodes.
I might combine my reviews of Episodes and
just do a Q&A on saturdays instead of doing
a review for each episode separately.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Even if I do a review of two episodes in the
same video I'll still give away one gift card
for each episode.
Right now click here for my episode 1 and
2 video and click here for my episode 3 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!